رحل درويش وبقيت اعماله هو وغيره من
مبدعين ومثقفين فلسطينيين وعرب شاهد على
مواكبه الفنون كافه مراحل النضال منذ
النكبه حامله المشروعا مقاوما يؤكد الحقوق
الفلسطينيه وينافع عنها نساله ضيوفنا عن
اهميه الفن كاداه للمقاومه وكيفيه تطور
الفنون الفلسطينيه رغم الضغوط والقيود
والى اي حد استفادت من التراث الفلسطيني
والتجارب الفنيه العالميه وما مدى نجاحها
في جذب اهتمام شعوب العالم للقضيه
الفلسطينيه
فانا لي
دو شط البح
ور
هو طلع من هون من عند هاي الجوزه وهاي
الرمانه وهاي الزيتونه اللي من اول من
خلقت هنا ثبتات سامبا يعني في انتماء
حقيقي للمكان يعني انا بحب اشتغل يعني مش
انه ابوي جابرني اجي اشتغل معه انا بستمتع
الامانه ضروري ضروري يكون الفنان جزء من
المكان اللي بيحكي عنه انا بالاغاني
ارسم الخارطه
الثقافيه تاعت فلسطين ما قبل النكبه للفن
دور عظيم في الحفاظ على تماسك
الفسيفساء بين ابناء الشعب الواحد
وكشعب فلسطيني يعاني من هذه التجزئات
والتقسيمات نحن في اشد الحاجه لدور الفن
الجمعي الذي يشمل الجميع من خلال من خلال
ادوات بسيطه فكره الكوفيه هي فكره لغه
تفاهم بيننا وبين الشعب السويدي يعني
جماعتنا لما كانوا يلقي الكلمه ما يجي
خمسه سته اشخاص لكن لما كنت امسك العود
واغني يجي ميه ويسقفوله ومبسوطين طب انا
لقيت انه بقدر افهم الناس قضيتي والناس
مبسوطه وفرحانه من الصغير للكبير الكل
بيجي يسمعنا الفن هو يعكس سيره الحياه وكل
شعب كل شعب يعني عنده ثقافته وفنه والمهم
في في هذا الموضوع انه هذا الفن
يوثق مسيره الشعب اليوم تم اثبات ان
الغناء والفنون عامه فيها الكثير من
الشفاء اذا استخدمت كاداه من اجل توعيه
الناس وتقريبهم من فطرتهم تنوعت الفنون
التشكيليه الفلسطينيه التي اشتبكت مع
الاحتلال وصولا الى فنون الشارع التي جعلت
جدرانها معرضا للفنانين والمقاومين في
كافه هباتهم وانتفاضاتهم
انا بشوف انه فن الشارع هو فن خارج عن
النص فهو كان عباره عن طريقه لتوصيل رساله
المقاوم
للمشاهد او للقارئ او للباحث
او للمحتل بالتاكيد فن الكاريكاتير فن
هادف وراقي جدا وهو يعد يعني سلاح قوي جدا
في المعركه ضد المحتل كيف لا ورسوماتنا
دوما توضع عليها العين الصهيونيه تتابع كل
ما يرسمه الفنان الفلسطيني لعل المرحله
الابرز التي ارتبطت بها عدسه الكاميرا
بفوهات البندقيه كانت مع بدايه مقاومه
التنظيمات الفلسطينيه منذ منتصف الستينيات
لتمتد بعدها الى يومنا هذا
هو فيلم الروائي الطويل الاول
وفكرته نابعه كمان من تجربتي الشخصيه طبعا
وهي مش قصتي انا يعني هي قصه الاف
العائلات في فلسطين اللي هو باختصار القسط
الفيلم هي قصه عائله تفرقت بسبب الجدار
طوال اكثر من 75 عاما حاول الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اخضاع الفن الفلسطيني وتفريغ ه
من دوره الوطني من خلال مجموعه من
الاجراءات التي كانت تمس المنتج الفنيه
احيانا او الفنان نفسه في احيان اخرى
حسام
[موسيقى]
مش غريب على الاحتلال الصهيوني الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
مضايقه الفنانين ودائما بستذكر وخوف
الغزاه من الاغنيات ومش بس من الاغنيات من
اللوحات من الرسمات من الشعر من القصائد
اللي
يونيس
[موسيقى]
لانه بيخافوا من الاعلام لانه اذا الاعلام
صار سلبي ضدهم معناته السويد متى توقف
ضدهن معناته
صار عندهم
اذا الاغنيه بتهدد شعب كامل معناته لازم
كلنا نعرف شو اهميه الكلمه والاغنيه في
مواجهه هذا المحتل اهم شيء الاثر يعني
لما الفنان بكون جمهور له بصير هذا
الجمهور يستنى فيه بصفي الفنان تحت يعني
طائله المسؤوليه نحن نعاني الامرين لانه
احنا
عشنا وولدنا في واقع متناقض يعني على من
ناحيه احنا بدنا نحافظ على تواصلنا مع
هويتنا الجمعيه هويتنا
الجمعيه مع باقي الشعب الفلسطيني من ناحيه
انت عايشه في واقع فرض فرض عليك انك تحملي
وثائق رسميه لا تمثلك ولا تعبر عن هويتك
ارشيفات الفلسطينيه يعني تخصنا وين موجوده
هل هي في ايادي فلسطينيه هل ممكن نحافظ
عليها للاجيال القادمه وهم بحسيت انه في
مشكله هذه الثوره الرقميه ومواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي ساهمت ايضا في ابراز فنانين لم
يتعاملوا مع صحف رسميه وبالتالي ساعه
ماساهمت في اثراء الفن الفلسطيني والرساله
الفلسطينيه الفنيه وانتشارها بشكل كبير
جدا نبشنا لهذا التراث تق ديمه واحيائه
واحياءه لانه فعلا مش موجود احيائه على
المسارح بين اطفالنا حتى يحملوا الجيل
الشاب للاجيال الجاي وعمليا عمال يقول انه
لا الشعب الفلسطيني الشعب اللي عنده مئات
القوالب الغنائيه هذا الشعب ما خلق امبارح
فلسطين هذا الشعب جذوره ضاربه في القدم
على ارض كنعان وقطع ارض الصير ولا تحدي
نتحدى
[موسيقى]